here we go again sony has once again
revealed the six playstation plus games
for April 2017 and I'm not expecting you
to react well at all this month we have
an online shooter a multiplayer
platformer a good old FPS under 2d
brawler for you both of this month PS
Vita games are available on ps4 so four
games in total available on the ps4 this
month you can get your grouping digital
hands all over these games from Tuesday
April the 4th right so let's do this
let's start with the big guns on ps4
first up is drawn to death an online
third-person shooter from the mind of
David Jaffe
the app now is probably the first thing
you'll notice and you'll either love it
or absolutely hate it it is set in a
teenager sketchbook so expect to see a
great deal of crumpled paper pen lines
and ridiculous character designs one of
the key features is described as
unconventional combat as each character
has a unique [ __ ] and the game world
is more complex than the art style
suggests this is a PlayStation exclusive
which is ultimately trying to reinvent
the shooter genre I am uncertain what my
opinion of this one is and I'm
struggling to get over the app style
what do you think please let me know
below next up is lovers in a dangerous
space-time which came out on the ps4 one
year ago this title can be played alone
or with up to four players you are
piloting a spacecraft with various
stations to control such as weapons
shields are on the engine too you will
be frantically moving between stations
to progress through the campaign and
defeat all four bossy in four player
this is pretty damn fun as you'll be
screaming at each other constantly it
kind of reminds me of over cooked in a
very strange way it does lose its appeal
one it's cleared alone but I'm very
tempted to try this with friends what do
you think if this video is of use please
lower the like and if you haven't joined
the PlayStation grenade bomb squad yet
then the subscribe button is calling to
you right let's get back to the ps3 a
more free games alien Ridge is the first
title on the PlayStation 3 first
released in 2013 this is an FPS in which
you murder countless aliens the more you
kill the more points you accrue these
points then going
your character stats such as boosting
defense or increasing your ammo storage
if you want a bit of backstory humans
and aliens are happily mining an
asteroid together before those
untrustworthy aliens turn on the human
race and it becomes a fight to the death
next up on the ps3 is invisible the lost
kingdom I can't say I knew anything
about this title and research proved
quite difficult from what I can gather
the game plays like a PSone classics or
such as spiral or Crash Bandicoot a more
modern version would probably be
Skylanders it's a very basic platformer
which looks quite lost in this day and
age with very basic combat elements - if
you can shed any light on this please
let me know in the comments below
finally the runt of the family the
little unlocks brother of the ps4 it's
the Vita 2 more titles for you to enjoy
both of which can be played on your ps4
first up is ten-second ninja which is a
blisteringly fast title with a real
pick-up-and-play feel your task is to
complete each level in only 10 seconds
no checkpoints no in-depth control
systems either simply platform the heck
out of the level throwing death stars
and other projectiles all over the place
this one should be worth a try well at
least for 10 seconds anyway finally
curses and chaos is a retro 2d wave bit
brawler it can be played in two player
co-op which I wasn't expecting to like
so much Lia and Leo make up a dynamic
duo we call our heroes and as you defeat
each wave the AI improved and the
occasional new enemy enters not a
groundbreaking title but someone out
there may love it so that's it I know
this video is probably going to be very
negative so please
sound off with abusive Sony below I
guarantee they won't read it so fill
your boots I'm downloading lovers in
dangerous space-time 10-second injure
and I'll try drawn to death - what are
you going to try I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade for more videos like
this one please like and subscribe see
you next time
[Music]